and depressed
and one of the things lesson if you
queued a second video
is that women are going to end up doing
this
second video please blessing
yeah he's gonna queue up
um yeah women are going to end up doing
this Pearl
I'm telling you
they don't understand what the Fallout
of feminism actually is
because women are no they say they don't
need men
We Don't Need No Man you don't need no
man girl I do you do I do but the
feminists the ultra feminist Super
Saiyan feminists the ones that are like
the Ultras
um say they don't I don't need a man I
Don't Need No Man for anything as a
matter of fact they prefer silicon
ew
they prefer their vibrators right
right they prefer the vibrators let's
see let's see what the Fallout feminism
is please listen let's see what this
woman has to say
oh
about one if you don't know what it is
Google it
so my very best friend JLo told me that
I had to have one they are amazing okay
comes in the mail I read on it it's
waterproof you can use it shopping
driving probably don't recommend that
either
standing walking sitting however you
want to use it you can use it okay don't
recommend it standing either and I'll
tell you why
so I'll decide I'm gonna use it in the
shower one because it's waterproof you
know okay so I gotta get in the shower
find my speed that I want
10 speed draw there's 10 speeds 10
speeds though okay I'm getting into it
next thing I know my knees start to
freaking book
my toes are curling I'm grasping for
anything okay with one hand because I'm
not letting go without
I'm grasping air will not catch you okay
you can't catch air air will not prevent
you from falling
learned that the hard way next thing I
know my eyes roll back in the back of my
head it started with memories from 40
years ago y'all I'm not but 36. then
next thing I know I'm in 1912 selling
the Titanic okay that's how far back my
eyes went in my head I'm selling the
Titanic we're fixing to hit the iceberg
when I come to I pop myself in the back
of the head my eyes rolled forward and I
realize that I have a death grip on
Rosie so had I died
in my shower that day
I would have died with a death grip on
Rosie with that's how my family would
have found me
now I do recommend it I don't recommend
it in the shower don't try to read the
directions either because they're in
Chinese
you cannot read the directions okay but
good luck in Godspeed
why why did you do that to me
I feel so uncomfortable why did you do
that to me bro women are celebrating
silicone I don't I don't understand why
you would put that on the internet I'm I
put a lot on the internet I understand
putting some things you know I
understand I tell funny stories on the
internet
but
ew I just don't you I don't want to hear
about that I don't want to know you no
The Fallout of feminism is
because women have been told for so long
that they no longer need a man
they are seeking certain things sexually
from silicone toys and this woman is
celebrating her silicon toy now I don't
have a problem as a man with being
replaced
I said the contact because I know that
silicon toys don't fix shelves
silicone toys do not kill spiders
silicone toys do not take you out on
dates silicone toys do not hug you at
night time Pearl look if they want to if
they want to replace men with that be my
freaking guess that is that sounds like
a her problem
you you
yeah I mean
um the a couple of shows ago we I spoke
about
um there were certain companies who deal
in sex toys who have seen like a 20 to
25 rise in you know sales and stuff and
I think that is one of the main
um one of the things about feminism or
Ultra feminism I've always called it
Super Saiyan feminism
um with this I don't need a man stuff is
that women are trying to replace men
with things that men cannot be replaced
by
and I think
um
women I used to spoke about you know
women being lonely
and I went on a website called
loneliness.com
it's called rootsofloneliness.com and it
says the common causes of female
loneliness include
not having friends on meaningful
connections with others
living away from family
spending too much time on social media
dealing with mental illness living alone
not having your romantic needs met
being single being a parent raising a
child alone struggles with
self-confidence self-esteem or
self-worth struggles with
eating disorders and body image
that sounds accurate yeah that sounds
right I feel like women being lonely is
a new phenomenon I feel like men have
always been lonely because most men have
not reproduced historically or I feel
like be a woman being lonely is almost
like a newer phenomenon yes because like
you at least work concubine or something
yeah you know you might not have gotten
like first round attention but do you
think you think women do with loneliness
worse than men
um
yeah I do I think like women are more
communal and we value relationships more
so when we're by ourselves like I feel
like man like women are more interested
in people where men are more interested
in things well one of the things that
says that women uh you know not having
any meaningful connections with others
yeah no I agree yeah yeah
I've even heard like some girls if
they're single and they also don't have
a good relationship with their immediate
family and I'm like I can't even imagine
a relation like a world where you grew
up in a great a huge family right yeah
and I can't even imagine not like going
home for Christmas some people are like
yeah I'm not going home for Christmas
I'm like what yeah I can't even imagine
like not going home for Christmas my mom
would kill me
I would literally be murdered like it'd
be like where's Pearl what what do you
think like the classic like
for men to look out for and also for
women like what do you think like the
classic things to look out for for like
an ultra feminist is
um because I would say
blue hair
I mean I feel like I like blue hair red
hair green hair I could see some that
are so obvious like you know a bunch of
tattoos tattoos piercings crazy colored
hair
um I I think you can also hear it in her
language like is she bitter
and I just think you don't want to date
a girl that's like bitter
but when you what do you mean by bitter
like like does she blame men for her
poor choices right you know like being a
lesbian like Cheyenne Reynolds said
she's gonna blame men for being a
lesbian but God yeah and that's what I
mean like like you can't blame all of
men for your poor decisions and it's
like I think some girls come out of it I
mean
I don't want to sit like some girls come
out like worse than us
I don't know you could just hear it in a
girl's like voice and the way she talks
if she's too damaged
okay you know what I mean because as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible